على الاقل من ميونخ والسد باسل الحاج جاسم
الباحث في العلاقات الدولي وسد باسم بلباس
اهلا وسهلا بك ايضا على
يعني نبدا من حيث انتهى هذا التقرير عن
معاهده نيو ستارت ايضا الى اي مدى ربما
تعليق المشاركه الروسيه في ايدي المعاهده
قد يغير مجرى الامور وبالتالي هذا الصراع
وهل يفتح باب تفوض ما بين واشنطن وموسكو
بالم الكرام في الواقع نحن امام سيناريو
مفتوح على كل الاحتمالات اما كما تفضلتي
نحن امام باب او نافذه جديده للتفاوض بين
موسكو واشنطن معروف ان موسكو طوال فتره
الازمه الاوكرانيه حتى قبل اشتعالها حربا
كانت تصر ان التفاوض يجب ان يكون مع
واشنطن تحديدا لاسباب كثيره العالم من
بينها تعتبر ان القياده الاوكرانيه هي
اداب يد واشنطن وايضا اوروبا ليس لديها
موقف دفاعي او امني بعيدا عن قرارات
واشنطن ايضا هناك احتمال اخر
وهو اننا على باب اشتعال حرب جديده ليس
حرب بالمعنى التقليدي انما التنافس واعاده
اهميه
التصنيع العسكري وخصوصا النووي منافسه
جديده مثل الفتره التي كانت خلال الحرب
البارده لكن مهم هنا جدا الاشاره ان
القرار هو تعليق وليس الخروج نهائيا يعني
ان هناك
نافذه اكبر ربما للتفاوض لكن هذا بالتاكيد
يعتمد على مجريات الاوضاع خصوصا في الساحه
الاوكرانيه طيب وسدد بس نعود الى هذه
الزياره التي اجراها وزير الخارجيه الصيني
الى موسكو نظيره الروسي وايضا التقى
الرئيس فلاديمير بوتين اهميه هذه الزياره
خصوصا بعد هذا الخطاب لبوتين وفي ظل ربما
هذه الاعين
الامريكيه التي تراقب ما سيحصل بين موسكو
في الاونه الاخيره
هناك العديد من الزوايا او الرسائل التي
يمكن استشفافها من هذه الزياره هي تاتي
على خلفيه اتهامات واتهامات
من اعلى المستويات الامريكيه تجاه بكين
بانها تقدم دعم عسكري لروسيا في الحرب
الاوكرانيه وايضا تاتي بعد ايام من مؤتمر
الامن الدولي في ميونخ حيث كشف وزير
الخارجيه الصيني عن مبادره ستقدمها الصين
مبادره للسلام في هذه الازمه لكن مما لا
شك فيه ان هناك قلق متزايد لدى بكين من ان
الدعم الغربي
المستمر لاوكرانيا قد يضعف بشده موسكو
حليفه بكين في التنافس مع الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه
وايضا صحيح ان الوضع اليوم يضعف روسيا
ويجعل الشراكات الاقتصاديه
والسياسيه
وكل الدعم التي تقدمه
بكين لموسكو يجعل لبكين الكلمه العليا في
علاقاتها الثنائيه مع موسكو الا انها لا
تريد ان ترى موسكو تخرج من هذا النزاع
مشلوله بالتالي كل هذه العوامل المجتمعه
يمكن ان تجعل من هذه الزياره في غايه
الاهميه لان اسوء سيناريوهات لبكين ان
تخرج موسكو خاسره من هذه المعركه